is apple robbing people with their ssd
and ram upgrade prices well yes and no
let's go ahead and see how apple stacks
up to their main competitors and see if
they're really ripping people off with
their prices and their performance now
some people say
it is
2022. how can apple get away with
offering eight gigs of ram and 256
gigabytes of storage on these expensive
new machines even the brand new m2
macbook air that's a higher price point
still sticks with the same amount of ssd
and ram that the retina macbook pro came
with 10
years ago and back then you could
upgrade that 8 gigabyte to 16 gigabyte
for you probably guessed it the same
price that you can upgrade right now 200
and shouldn't technology get cheaper as
time goes on
well yeah but we also have some major
differences first off
the ssds the apple that are coming out
with now are way faster than before the
256 gig in these macbooks with apple
silk and chips go up to about 2
300 for the read and over 2
800 megabytes per second for their right
compared to about that 400. now apple
has been very consistent with their
upgrade prices over the years and
they've never been cheap but they have
offered some decent values at times for
performance for example when they made
the jump from the 2020 macbook airs to
the m1s the speeds of the ssds got much
faster going from 1300 megabyte per
second read to
2800 and from 800 right all the way up
to 2300
and at that time ssds were more
expensive and then considering the fact
that for a more expensive dell you were
getting speeds of 1080 for right in 1900
for read with the same capacity compared
to the macbooks that was actually a
pretty good deal and the same thing went
when apple released their redesigned 14
and 16 inch macbook pros with ssds that
went over 7 000 megabytes per second
and they kept the prices for upgrades
the same as before so in those machines
if you're dropping an extra 200 that is
a decent value but i believe the times
have now shifted in 2022 for one you can
now get a good 500 gigabyte ssd for 75
bucks on amazon and of course you cannot
put that into your macbook pro and
second we now have some great laptops
like dell's xps 13 plus that are
offering fast ssds for great prices so
now let's get into the comparison with
the competition starting out with the
laptop that i really like microsoft's
surface laptop 4
this thing has a nice squarish display
it has good speakers very nice ones it's
a great all-around laptop and it also
comes with 8 gigs of ram for base and
256 gigs of storage taking a look at
their pricing microsoft is also charging
200 bucks to upgrade from 8 to 16 gigs
of ram and the same thing goes for the
storage up to 512
and if you do drop that extra 200 bucks
to go up to 512 their read speed is only
2 280 compared to 2825
and the right is
170 compared to 2
900 on the macbook air 512. now that is
just one laptop a microsoft's option
it's a premium laptop let's set that
aside let's look at another option from
razer they also gave you the base model
of 8 gig and 256 and then if you want to
upgrade you can't do that you have to
jump up to the 1500 model which doubles
your ssd and ram and gets you a little
bit faster processor now thankfully the
performance is better than the surface
laptop we have 2200 right and
2700 read so technically they're
charging the same as apple now you also
have that additional hundred bucks to
give you the better processor but of
course the m1 still destroys that
processor and the laptop as a whole is
better overall and now we have the m2
coming out now i also looked at some
think pads i looked at some lg's
samsung's but the situation is fairly
similar if some have higher specs some
are actually more expensive than like
the macbooks
or it's just really slow so let's skip
to what i'm actually impressed with and
that is dell's latest xps lineup we have
the regular xps that starts at a
thousand bucks with a slow processor and
a bad screen we've reviewed those before
and then we have their brand new xps 13
plus which is very impressive now right
out of the get-go their price tag is
actually higher than the new m2 macbook
pro and air and it does come with a much
worse screen slower processor but they
do give you 512 gigs of ssd out of the
box you still get 8 gigs of ram but
instead of costing you 200 to upgrade
like with max and apple it only costs
you 100
to make that jump that is excellent and
it is new fast ram and then as far as
the ssds to upgrade a one terabyte it is
another 100 jump not a 200 jump that it
costs you with apple's macbooks now not
only is it cheaper it is actually better
first off that ssd is actually removable
so you can upgrade it yourself
but with that you wouldn't really want
to because look at these speeds we have
5 000 megabytes per second right
compared to 2900 on the macbook and 6
700 read compared to 2825
that is
incredible and that just shows you
what they could do when they have a
little slot on their macbook you just
buy market
ssds for great prices and then of course
apple is soldering theirs in so that is
incredible now of course this laptop
they did some really weird things uh
like not even giving you a headphone
jack you can get an adapter that'll ship
separately to you and you only have two
ports and of course i have a touch bar
thing i'm still very excited to check
this thing out
if you guys want to see a comparison hit
that subscribe button down below
because we will be comparing it but it's
still cool to see a good value and a
company is trying to be competitive
and giving you these kind of prices now
of course with that with apple's
ram it's not the same as ram on these
machines that is unified they have to
build it into the chip itself so that
makes that more expensive and you don't
need as much ram as you do with the
windows system we actually have done
comparisons showing how we're comparing
8 gigs to 16 comparing intel to apple
silicon windows and mac showing you that
8 gigs performs much closer to 16 when
you had that in the past without unified
memory because you have a lot less
duplication
that is used for graphics it's a lot
more optimized so even though it costs
more money they're using it with a
different process you don't need to
upgrade uh and get as much as you did
previously for most tasks so as far as
apple robbing people
i mean some of these prices are crazy
paying 200 bucks for 128 gig of extra
storage
it's too much definitely too much we
tell a lot of you guys buy an external
ssd we've showed off the savings many
times works with thunderbolt and usbc
you can plug it into any computer you
can keep it with you if you upgrade your
mac that's what i would suggest for you
guys and as far as their ram
it is expensive but you don't need as
much as you think make sure you guys
check out these those other videos that
i talked about now what i do think
they're robbing people with are their
other devices not the macbooks but the
ipads for example the ipad air this is
just
crazy
if 64 gigs at the base that's not enough
for most people if you're gonna be
really using this device but they just
skipped out the 128 gig option that they
let you get on other devices and you
have to spend 150 bucks to jump up to
256 which of course gets you really
close to the ipad pro once again getting
you to spend more money now with this
external options with external disease
aren't as useful it's a much more
portable device and there's other issues
that i talked about in my ipad os 16
video now for the ipad pro it gets even
worse and i think completely unexcusable
if you want to have a good amount of
storage to use as a pro device for media
editing you might want to get one
terabyte of storage but as you see it
cost you 400 bucks to go from 512 to one
terabyte that is
insane where at the same time for 75
bucks you can get uh one m.2 stick like
i showed you the samsung for 500 gigs
now that is because not only are they
charging you these kind of outrageous
prices but they're locking in a 16 gig
ram upgrade with that capacity as well
so if you don't need the ram and now we
know ipad os 16 will use swap so you
don't need that extra ram
uh but you do want more storage you're
out of luck you have to get it or vice
versa where the same exact m1 chip in a
macbook air you can choose the storage
or the ram even if the ram is built in
so this is how apple is robbing people
of their money forcing them to buy
options that they might not even need so
that is my perspective i hope that apple
at least upgrades and puts better ssds
in some of these devices when they're
charging this much money
and overall wants to lower their prices
but the lowering price part of it i
don't think that's going to happen
because they've been very consistent
with the options and the prices they
give people and the only way they would
want to change it is if people stop
buying macbooks but people are buying
these apple silicon macbooks like crazy
and switching over from windows systems
and they're willing to pay that price to
get all the other amazing benefits that
they offer you guys let me know your
thoughts down below what you think about
this whole situation check out some of
those ram comparisons right over there
to show you how powerful apple's unified
memory is how efficient it is click
above to subscribe this with max and i
will see you guys in the next video
[Music]